hello everybody oh hello a man stocked
for months by the Slender Man has fallen
into a deep coma due to the slender
sickness trapped in his mind he is taken
back to a place dear to him his
childhood home but he's not alone
Slenderman has followed him can you find
enough childhood mementos to break out
of the coma or will he find you and
destroy you
that's the question hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to
slender mansion alright
as per yuge I'm playing this as soon as
it was released I have no idea what I'm
getting into fine twelve twelve mementos
that's different and the glow stick
mechanic is back alright
this looks nice hey cool statue now
school's a lion whatever right so um
yeah this is what I thought was gonna
happen you're able to actually go
upstairs and I'm assuming there's
probably a downstairs as well but either
way it opens up some more interesting
stuff so ah
see even more upstairs so with the new
mechanics and what I've learned from the
last slender games that I've played woo
door I like that
very creepy atmospheric even ma but from
what I learned in the past slender games
and in this one don't look behind you
find it and get the F out of here all
right so I don't think I'm looking for
pages it said mementos that's all about
but I'm trying to find off see there it
is down seer you can go downstairs I'm
just taking it real slow there's no
reason to hurry I don't even know what
these mementos look like but there's no
reason to hurry because lemon he doesn't
even spawn for the first few one so I'm
just going to be scouting a bit
is this another locked door oh holy crap
this to lock doors one upstairs one
downstairs there might be more I'm not
exactly sure but this is gonna make it
really really difficult because at least
in him it's just off lightning lightning
was not scary it's at least in hey
what's that Elementor he was like a nice
clean loop is that not a cookie I have
the cookie Oh Oh cookie I guess with
childhood memories it makes more sense I
didn't I haven't been clicking on
anything holy crap I might have missed
up
I don't know but still early on no need
to take it too seriously not yet anyway
Wow
oh that was my flashlight on a frying
pan what I don't know
yeah surprise I was actually with the
flashlight on okay um oh man I'm so
gonna get lost in here it's like not
even funny
Oh another one another one are you
kidding me
holy crap no way Oh what I need three
keys holy hell
I haven't even found one key and then
it's intense
all right come on out Slendy man what
you got
yeah I've been passing like Oh key key
upstairs key downstairs key which one is
it try upstairs first it's the right way
to go I'm not exactly sure
hey wait that's two painting something
it's glowing
it's very luminescent ah I gotcha I
gotcha all right that's three of twelve
not bad for my first start spending can
go F out ah yeah go go bad timing Slendy
I just told you to F off
sorry about that cool Oh God
oh he looked weird what's different
about him oh oh hi hey I think he's
longer you know I mean here okay alright
uh I've been in here haven't I
I mean I don't even know where I've been
before
golly I swear I'm gonna punch in circles
no oh I must I totally must have passed
by some stuff that I should have gotten
before Oh something a doughnut or a
pebble rock 4 of 12 y 12 why is it gotta
be 12 ah don't look by me don't look by
me that's one rule that I cannot break I
cannot break that cuz he was it and I'll
go on there a way ah yes
more Oh No oh is that the one key unlock
all the doors or what I'm gonna assume
it unlocked all the doors and if there's
an upstairs and a downstairs that means
four per level so maybe I got all four
on the mid-level and now I just need to
go get all the ones down here and then
I'll be on my merry way
nice oh what's that ah I don't know what
it was like a box of so don't look
rhyming scheme um forward ah don't look
baby never Honolulu
hey Baba giggle you boo boo who
this back upstairs I don't want to be
down here I want to get all that are I
do want to be down here or I don't want
to be down here but I don't want to go
back up again ooh
go away honey go away no not you
good news nad do douche Hey look and
donator bored
Oh is my thinking out of there that's
okay I need to donate them kill me don't
kill me bro oh is that ah got another
one that's two more down here so if I
get two more I'm gonna assume that's all
of them and I give officers span by 12
this has got to be 12 over here
something grandfather clock
don't tell me that's actually an item
have a nappy fun times I run fast for
holding a grandfather clock is that it
oh that's key then lumpy Dolph's Turkey
hmm it's one more item out here I gotta
find it man oh no seems I just picked
I'm so strong oh man say whoa ah
no Lenny what you got huh yeah I squat
eight thousand pounds on a bad day do
you even lift bro subscribe
Oh get out of here man this game is
gonna be longer if it is but I had to
deal with
look back no no no no back then I'll
find that phone some way is that phone
and this oh I would've totes missed that
don't get me wrong I'm not a row I just
see I swear I've like missed items that
I thought were glowy but they weren't
like here I haven't been clicking around
I'm gonna yeah it's rising not doing
that chase music anymore I'm hoping
please be the key
please be three up here oh thank you so
much oh oh no oh no oh no oh
oh is that something looks like it's
going whatever it is I don't know it's
painting no give me give me give me that
painting that that lady fixed up of the
Jesus painting you know done that is why
I wherever it wasn't
there's nothing here oh god I'm trapped
in a room don't get me don't get me okay
I think that's the sound of me dying hmm
the slender sickness all right let's go
get us get this early for my job can you
find enough childhood mementos to break
out of the coma will he find you and
kill your mind trapping you in there
turn on darkness I was the last line I
didn't get ooh what did I get 10 11 I
don't even know I think I got 1000 how
did he get me he was like behind me at a
distance
sponsored by Daniel Edenfield
classic lead mock's teen great guy I'm
an artist ray Burgess great guy didn't
read that last one probably a great guy
okay no wasting time I forgot to drop
the glow sticks and whatnot but it
doesn't matter
I've got intense brain action going on
memorizing okay right off the bat
oh yeah then how about this if I got the
key like right then in there let me just
grab this oh wait is it is it they're
all in the same spot
what cuz there's so many okay let me
just grab that go to the basement make
sure I clear out the basement
I've already know where things are up
here so if there are more in the
basement I want to make sure I get all
those
and then uh I don't know what I'll do
don't ask me what I'll do because I'm
not a good sure nice but this way I have
more set the other key it's like it yeah
okay got the GUP stare ski man I got the
keys right away this play for in a bit
hang on the soapbox scooch-scooch-scooch
aboot
get out of here they're on the same
place and I just need to get the
grandfather clock and the other thing I
don't remember what it was
ah you you you this and then something
over here and I don't know if that
wasn't it that was way out that's
another way up I could go oh there he is
oh [ __ ] oh good I don't look behind me
okay it's a donator board that way go
this way grandfather clocks in the other
side but there's another thing over here
I remember correctly the roll of film
that's right now I get the grandmother
it fit beautifully we do you need just
printing in the basement excuse me as I
left this clock oh yeah oh not even
happy oh yeah money can't kill me
clock didn't even have a I was looking
behind me I did it again I'm sorry I'm
so sorry Slendy excuse me as I ran away
like a big baby it's not there I don't
know I don't care not looking behind me
I got four down there I'm pretty sure
that with all of them down here I think
there are five up here and then three
enough they're all in the same Plaza one
on the bed one in the sink there was
that phone and oh this is the cookie
cookie and this is the painting no no no
go away honey
go away he does look different by the
way I didn't mention that before but
he's got like more arms or something
which is ah doctor - got it
what's that gone there's nothing in
yours to the right oh my life
oh I went wrong way tonight oh ah yes I
was this is the painting okay over Oh
how's that a childhood memory it's like
two cloaked figures in the background
mother you know I don't even know even
want to know another thing anyone wants
to know this is wrong
I'm gonna go I have a hate just one more
I've missed one more somewhere I don't
know where I'm so [ __ ] if I could on
the think the rock or the donut that's
right yeah yes yes
Oh get me out of here oh I swear Oh get
me out of here coming out of here
Damaris Lindy don't get me don't get me
Sonny don't get a I can win that I'll
get it suck it up you can pick up a
grandfather clock I guess I'll be
understandable not being able to sprint
with a grandfather clock in your back
pocket
come on come on let's go let's go let's
do this first one was over here let's
just pick up the pace just a little bit
where was it it was in here wasn't it no
there was not on the liar dirty dirty
liar
where was it
this was it keep going don't look back
don't look back you got in there come on
come on get it get it get it get it all
wrong okay bye Oh No
Oh
ah
oh god I never got my hurry
I did it Oh Oh
rabbi I know it's getting dark right
there
all right
whoa
oh crap
all right
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you mark Steen and thank you guys
so much for making
any friend will make
I've been chased I never felt chased
like that
whoo thank you guys so much for watching
love these love these mounts in the face
to be sending them out right
thank you again everybody for watching
and as always see you